[Music]
there's a chance that before you had an
idea of what an amoeba was you had an
image of them in your head built on
headlines describing invisible brain
eaters or pop-culture references to
their simple amorphous bodies
tardigrades and hydras and stent errs
are magnificent but amoebas they're
classic when asked how he named his
iconic California record store amoeba
music co-owner mark weinstein said quote
the word amoeba came up because it
sounded good with music we just wanted
it to be a psychedelic kind of name that
students would relate to record stores
aren't alone in finding familiarity with
amoebas they show up often in writing
like a cultural ambassador of the micro
cosmos that serves as a handy reference
for anything that is blobby that splits
that is undeveloped but as is the truth
of many amuse the reality of amoebas is
so much more complicated and weird than
the flattened image of a formless
ancestor that we project our literary
needs onto
the very idea of amoeba as a category is
a relic from the 19th century
classification of single-celled
eukaryotes or protists which group the
organisms into one of four types that
seemed to largely correspond to how they
moved sporozoites ciliates and amoeba
according to this classification amoebas
are the ones with pseudopodia extensions
of the cytoplasm that helped the amoeba
eat and move around amoeboid protists
were largely grouped together into a
class or phylum called Sarco Dena a name
derived from the word SAR code which was
in turn a French version of the Greek
word for fleshy these classifications
were built on the tools of the time
namely microscopes and what scientists
could observe through them and so the
pseudopodia that defined amoebas were
also used to differentiate them from one
another some of these pseudopodia are
likely what you would imagine loose and
spreading but Helia ZOA are also amoebas
their bodies extending outward
indistinct spiking rays that are
actually pseudopodia held rigid by inner
microtubules and the bodies of amoebas
despite the collective blob we often
envisioned show the same range some
amoebas called testate amoebas actually
build shells around themselves they're
single-celled constructors these shells
vary across species in how they are made
and what they look like
this young arcella is colorless but as
it ages the storage of iron and
manganese in its shell will turn it
brown unfortunately while the shells of
testate amoeba can be stunning they can
also be difficult to record because the
weight of the glass coverslip on the
slide can break those shells in terms of
size amoebas can range from microns to
centimeters
making them sometimes visible to our
naked eyes
the amoeba pehle miksa is somewhere in
between but even though they usually
measure in a little under one millimeter
they are still considered a giant amoeba
to get a sense of just how big a giant
is in the micro cosmos
here's a pelham ixa and here is a
tardigrade remember tardigrades have
thousands of cells and that pehle miksa
has just the long inside of that one
giant cell is a body lacking in many
organelles we associate with eukaryotes
there is no mitochondria powering the
cell no Golgi body moving things around
it does however house endosymbiotic
bacteria and multiple nuclei while some
fella miksa might have only a few nuclei
others have been found with several
thousand the simplicity of the Pella
Nick Saban II was for a long time the
basis of the belief that it is primitive
predating the advent of those other
eukaryotic parts the truth as we will
see later and gets murkier as we try to
piece together 2 billion years of
eukaryotic history
amoebas move in a way that is very
helpfully described as amoeboid
locomotion a combination of extending
pseudopodia and altered shape and as
this single-celled creature makes its
way around in that particularly amoeboid
way you should know that this kind of
movement is going on inside of you right
now it's driving your white blood cells
around for example as they monitor for
any external threats white blood cells
share another amoeboid feature
phagocytosis amoebas don't have mouths
so when it comes time to eat they use
their pseudopodia to trap their prey and
engulf it drawing the food into its own
compartment called a vacuole where it
will then be digested and yes some
species will feed on nerve tissue
including your brain if the opportunity
presents itself but the meal of choice
for many amoebas is not necessarily so
terrifying
this Vampirella for instance sounds
menacing because of its name and sure
when it wants to feed the Vampirella
pokes ahold into its prey and begins to
suck out the contents but its primary
food is algae and sometimes fungi even
the occasional microscopic worm when
they're done eating they form a cyst
creating a wall around themselves as
they digest their meal and then divide
given how important pseudopodia are to
the way amoebas live it's easy to
understand why they were used in our
early attempts to make sense of the
micro cosmos but in more recent decades
as we've developed the tools to
investigate life based on DNA our
categorization of amoebas has changed as
well no longer lumped together in the
Sarco Deena most amoeboid protists are
now divided between two super groups one
is amoebas OA which includes the Pella
miksa the other group is rise area which
includes helios OA but there are some
lineages of amoebas that weave their way
out of these groups as these changing
evolutionary trees shift our
understanding of amoebas they've raised
questions about just what we call
primitive Pella miksa for example was
considered to be among the earliest
eukaryotes because they lacked
mitochondria more recent evidence
however indicates that they're actually
the descendants of eukaryotes that had
mitochondria it's just that for some
reason Pella mixes seems to have lost
theirs and if someone would like to do
some research to try and determine why
Pella miksa is better off without
mitochondria please do it because we are
very curious even our understanding of
how amoebas reproduce has had to be
corrected our vision of a simple
organism simply dividing is now
complicated by interwoven lineages that
mix sexual and asexual reproduction at
the risk of getting too circular with
our references our understanding of
amoebas is it's well what like amoebas
themselves shifting full of splits and
divisions and yet somehow encompassing
amoebas are scattered now left right up
and down the evolutionary branches
sometimes as single cells sometimes as
part of other organisms even us it's
fitting them that we see amoebas as
useful touchstones or metaphors in books
or music or wherever else they show up
our bodies after all are built out of
the lessons that nature learned with
them thank you for coming on this
journey with us as we explore the unseen
world that surrounds us and thank you
especially for all of our patrons on
patreon who let us do this wonderful
thing we hope that you enjoy it as much
as we do if you want to see more from
our master of microscopes James Weiss
check out Jam and germ on Instagram and
if you want to see more from us there's
always a subscribe button somewhere
nearby